[Music]  [Applause]  goes to the basket  boy simmons uncontested had a layup but  he  leaves it for thy bull who makes  something out of it and is headed to the  line  well but that's when you know that the  game is in your head  that's a dunk for ben simmons right  there you gotta and i know you got to  decide what you got  the free throws but ben simmons you  gotta shoot that shot  be confident that if you do get fouled  that you can make  the free throw with an and one so now  that that two now turns into what could  be  a one point possession instead of a  possible three with the five on the dunk  by simmons that psychological piece to  it as well